Colson is with us in Philadelphia i
Colson how are you oh I'm okay Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well I'm kind of opposite end of my path
as the people just as the Deaf
pre-screen that I'm facing a an awful
lot of debt and just trying to get
trying to get a handle on and I've been
listening to you for a little while and
how much debt do you have well not
including our house my wife and I have
about two hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars in tests good lord
what's that on well hundred seventy six
it is student loan who's the doctor or
lawyer I'm a doctor I have about a
hundred thousand student loans and my
wife houses about 76
gotcha all right and what's your
household income last year we brought on
235 Wow congratulations very well done
sir
so why can't you live on nothing and pay
off this debt really quick you know I
think that I think that we can and I
think that you just listening to the
last half hour so you pointed out a lot
of things that I've done long as I let
my money take control of me rather than
taking control of it and if I just do
some simple math Coulson you got two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
debt right or 225 thousand dollars in
debt okay so if I do some simple math
and I say a hundred thousand dollars a
year towards that and your debt free in
just a little over two years right but
that means you're living on half of what
you've been living on and it's time for
y'all to stop living like doctors and
start living like broke doctors I mean
what tops you from doing that well the
first step in your your baby steps is a
you know not not getting in more debt
and just that's that's been the tough
one I've I my wife has managed our
finances for the last five years and
I've just been out for five years and
I've been trying to last couple weeks to
just sort of get a handle on
and find out where where all the money
has been going and everything and it was
it's amazing how much those uh payments
on all this stuff will add up we have
everything is on pain how much as much
as your how much is your house payment
$1,900 a month okay that's not out of
line with your income so what I would
challenge you to do is I'm just looking
at this very simplistically very
primitively and I think you start there
and then that forces you to look at the
details but let's pretend like a guy
making 250,000 dollars a year that was
living on a hundred and fifty and that
left them 100 and that means you're
going to have to cut your lifestyle way
down you guys eat out you travel you do
a bunch of crap you're not going to be
able to do if you're going to get your
mess cleaned up here but you can do that
you know what I'm suggesting is radical
cutting of your lifestyle and that there
by getting out of debt quicker what we
have found and you do a lot of stuff as
a doc that works the same way but we're
in the behavior world but what we found
is the faster somebody gets out the
higher the probability is that they're
going to get out and of course the math
says that the faster you're going to get
out the deeper you have to cut in
lifestyle and so the deeper you cut in
lifestyle is related to how passionate
you are about getting this out of your
life for ever and ever amen
and here's the thing well you guys would
be so rich so fast and be able to do so
much not only for yourselves and for
your family but for others if you had no
debt because you have this tremendous
income but it's all going out the door
to other people yeah all this work I've
done all these years to become a doc all
that sacrifice all those hours all those
and all of the stuff you've been through
in your life and now it's all being
given to somebody else that would make
me mad if i sat and thought about it for
a little while and I want you to get so
mad that you're willing at that you're
willing to cut the lifestyle to nothing
so you get out of debt really really
fast
that's how I would tell you to do it sir
I'm honored to have you call in and I
think you're going to do it call
you know how you're doing